[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
this is where it began this is where the
fuse was lighted it began with the
arrest by white officers of the
California Highway Patrol of two young
Negroes one on a charge of drunk driving
the other his brother his passenger
their mother who lives nearby came to
the scene there was an argument there
was a scuffle by then a crowd of several
hundred Negroes had gathered the story
of police brutality quickly spread
through the community up the street a
block or so in that direction a church
where a Negro leaders pleaded for peace
and were rejected found that way the
busy intersection where cars were
overturned and burned where a television
technician was pulled from his wagon and
almost beaten to death
it was the most widespread most
destructive racial violence in American
history
the burning and looting the shooting and
beating went on for nearly a week 34
persons were killed all but five of any
Negroes police chief Parker described
Los Angeles Negro rioters as monkeys in
a zoo and Negro leaders have more than
once called for his removal in creating
the situation where was the failure on
the part of the city the county the
schools this I think is one of the
difficulties in meeting this is that
we're trying to find a failure other
than the people themselves and this is a
very dangerous move because it serves to
sort of sanctify their acts every
grievance that was had by the people who
started this thing there has been
nothing done to solve it the only thing
that was done was that massive forces
were brought in to suppress the actual
overt action how has it affected you
it's getting tired of being pushed
around by you like this off now pushed
around how badly it's stopping us on the
street kicking into the doze taking down
a police station you keep your teeth in
well they're stopping people on the
street now they've been done a long time
before now during this entire incident
we've heard constant references to
respect for law and order and more
particularly what they mean is respect
for law enforcement how to really
understand the problems of these people
you'd have to understand what law
enforcement has meant to them for a
hundred years
we're talking about the white man's law
enforcement that's responsible for many
of their parents being chased out of the
south on one pretext or another under
those conditions you can understand that
the people aren't going to be reverent
about law enforcement and the men who
enforce the law what would make it
better what herd maker all the rioting
stop I don't think it ever stop really
never I mean that may not be like this
that it'll never stop I don't think the
cone Commission sought to answer
questions about watts can it happen
again so serious and explosive is the
situations as the Commission that unless
it is checked the August riots may be
only a curtain raiser - what could blow
up one day in the future what shall it
avail our nation if we can place a man
on the moon but cannot cure the sickness
in our cities this is bill stout for CBS
reports in Los Angeles good night
[Music]
out of the ashes of this community I
think that is an opportunity to build a
better society in terms of Economic
Security better housing conditions
better schools and to deal with the
police problem to make Los Angeles a
model city for the nation
Thomas Bradley was sworn in today as
mayor of Los Angeles the largest city in
this country ever to have a black mayor
Bradley is a former policeman and the
son of a Texas sharecropper tonight it's
not just a victory for Tom Bradley but a
victory for progress a victory for our
children thank you very much Daryl Gates
had spent 28 years working his way
through the ranks to the top job he had
been chief Parker's driver and bodyguard
his heir apparent I'm gonna put my stamp
on this organization this will be a
Daryl gates department blacks and
liberals that become intensely critical
of what they charge is excessive use of
force by the Los Angeles Police
Department
that is dangerous many Americans think
of Hollywood when they think of Los
Angeles but Los Angeles is also the port
of entry for America's new immigrants
from Asia and from Latin America
in the last 15 years more than two
million immigrants from around the world
according to the city many of the city's
new small businesses are the American
Dream of the foreign-born our city is a
stunning ethnic and cultural mosaic we
have forged a sense of identity of
common concern and destiny in the late
dr. Martin Luther King's words I am
honored to stand here today and look out
upon faces of many different colors
intermingle like the waters of a river
yet I see only one face the face of the
future thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
one two three I am pleased to announce
that at midnight tonight
all United States and coalition forces
will suspend offensive combat operations
this is not a time of euphoria certainly
not a time to gloat but it is a time of
pride pride in our troops pride in our
nation and the people who strengthen
resolve made victory quick decisive and
just this latest Gallup poll shows
people in the United States feeling
positive about their country and their
president following the Allied victory
of the dahle residents will have to
drink shower and consume 10 percent less
water
mayor Bradley signed the water
conservation measure today give honey
economy looks none too good in fact they
keep saying that the recession is the
only thing pulling us out of inflow
shifty 7°
bulletin klaudia 60 was Long Beach
partly cloudy at 60 and Lancaster
[Music]
[Applause]
an unusual twist in a case of alleged
race-based police brutality in Los
Angeles neither the police nor the
suspect knew that a home video camera
had captured the scene it began as a
high-speed chase and ended early Sunday
morning with the motorist a black male
being brutally beaten and kicked the
victim was struck as many as fifty six
times and suffered several broken bones
56 times that's what the American public
saw on video George holiday lives across
the street
he had his video camera out and it
recorded what happened as the suspect
was being arrested the camera sort of
ready and looked across the street
that's when I saw that the action was
going on the suspect identified as
Wadley run King King who is married and
has two stepchildren was on parole after
serving time for armed robbery his wife
says that's no excuse for what happened
it was a traffic violation how come they
just couldn't arrest him and give him
some kind of fine or something I'd had
to beat the mess out of them like that
doctors said that he suffered a
concussion one of his eye sockets was
pulverized his cheekbone was so pushed
in from the blows to his face that it
would require reconstructive surgery
from what I've seen none of the
prisoners of war from American forces
taken by Saddam Hussein came back beaten
that badly Los Angeles police say the
incident was not racially motivated but
the black community is not buying that
about 300 members of the n-double a-c-p
marched on police headquarters today
this is an aberration this is something
that should never have happened we had
in place all of the procedures that
would keep it from happening those
procedures fell down because of human
error
the ACLU said it receives about 55 calls
a week from people alleging police
brutality
the incident early Sunday morning is not
an isolated incident the difference this
time is that we have the proof
[Music]
do you have any idea at all how many
times you were hit by a club what do you
remember about that every time several
times and in stones and cake that's from
some kind of device that they use the
shocking you gotta be kicked out of that
what makes you say they got a kick out
of him because of how long he left it
him it was like they had a little toy
and they wanted to see how at work what
kinds of things did you hear from the
officers did you hear any kind of slurs
at all what do you mean slurs were there
any kind of racial comments made at all
Oh Rachel no I didn't know I didn't you
you can cut this from the tape if you
want but rods family has made it very
clear that they're not looking to turn
this into a racial crusade mr. King
doesn't want to make make it ours though
they did it just because he was a black
man that may have been incidental to it
and there may be personal motives that
these officers had we don't know about
yet but at the present time it doesn't
seem like that
[Music]
as you know the District Attorney's
Office has been conducting an
investigation into the beating of Rodney
King and I am announcing today that we
have obtained indictments against four
Los Angeles police officers for their
role in the beating of mr. King LAPD
officer Lawrence Powell
Timothy wind Theodore Briceno and
sergeant Stacey Koon have been indicted
for assault with a deadly weapon and for
excessive use of force under color of
authority officer Powell and Wynn and
sergeant poon are further charged with
inflicting great bodily injury in the
brutal attack that has now been
witnessed by millions of people under
California law these are felonies
punishable by up to seven years in state
prison
sergeant Koon and officer Powell have
also been indicted for filing false
reports all four officers surrendered
this morning to the district attorney's
office they had been arrested
fingerprinted and photographed thank you
very much
this is World News Tonight with Peter
Jennings sitting in tonight in
Washington Ted Koppel
good evening the evidence is new it's
dramatic and it's devastating to those
Los Angeles police officers involved in
the March 3rd beating of that black
motorist one of the two officers who
wielded batons that evening relate a
message after the arrest to another car
saying quote sounds almost as exciting
as our last call it was right out of
gorillas in the mist
one policeman involved in the beating
said quote I haven't beaten anyone this
bad in a long time another joke later
saying I'm sure the lizard didn't
deserve it Mayor Tom Bradley said the
transcript raises more questions about
Police Command I think it has been
devastating to the image of the city and
especially to our Police Department it's
very apparent that some not all but some
of those officers are clearly out of
control and they have to ultimately be
willing to take a good hard look at the
leadership of the department
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. president all of us I think have
been stunned by what has happened and I
can't imagine that the chief or anybody
else in the city would condone the kind
of conversation that took place both
electronically
and by voice in that Foothill division
that night blacks are not animals
they're not lizards they're not Apes
they're not gorillas any more than any
of us are they're human beings the first
way to open the door to brutalizing
people in anyone any place is to cheapen
their worth as human beings and when I
read the transcripts of the conversation
I was appalled but the ability to freely
converse in racist terminology suggests
a level of tolerance for that kind of
discussion that that is unacceptable by
any standard of decency well first of
all this is a department that this
council has supported over and over
again
this is a police department that has
supported you each of you and I just
tell you this if you don't speak out on
behalf of the men and women Los Angeles
Police Department of theirs serve the
people this city well if you don't do
that at this crucial moment in our
history now I'm going to tell you you're
gonna have a police department that is
not going to be the kind of department
that you want the kind of apartment that
people deserve mr. Wu thank you I want
to know did you mean that as a threat in
other words that if if if I or other
members of the council are going to be
criticizing you or the department are
you saying that you will will withhold
support of these services to fight crime
in our districts that is the most
insulting thing I have heard on this
council floor and all the time
and I've been here a lot longer than
you've been alive absolutely not it's a
professional organization what do you
think we are
[Music]
she'll be up against the wall and
started straightening I cannot breathe
if you tried to kick me in the testicles
he drew me aside and said get your hat
we found one case where a dog attacked
and bent the chest of a 16 year old girl
the dogs are quite large and aggressive
they will rip away flesh and muscle they
will tear out blood vessels and they
will sometimes break bones please send
our kids completely conflicting messages
they're in our schools every single day
and yet our kids see them on TV beating
a man like a dog the police are trained
to approach black men as criminals first
and citizens second but before you leave
South Central you need to understand
that verbal abuse happens here every day
and every night
assume the position sit on the
curb
[Applause]
and when we speak out the first thing
they say is why are they getting so
Restless
people are talking about taking this to
the streets and we ain't talking about
just marching
[Applause]
another widely publicized incident
captured on videotape in Los Angeles
this grainy security camera videotape
graphically depicts the last few moments
of fifteen-year-old Latasha Harlan's
life store owner soon-ja dude thought 15
year-old Latasha Harlan's was going to
steal some orange juice she had the
money in her hand you can see the money
in the videotape and the suspect grabbed
the backpack and there became a physical
altercation over the backpack and as our
victim turned to walk away from the
scene the suspect raised a weapon and
shot the victim in the back of the head
Latasha was an ace duty honor roll
student she got money every week for her
allowance oh she did not have to steal
orange to the store clerk a Korean woman
is now in jail the black community is
outraged over the killing
the n-double-a-cp is demanding the clerk
be tried for murder the case has become
a symbol of tensions between two large
groups in this ethnically diverse City
african-americans and the Koreans who
become successful merchants in many of
the poorest black neighborhoods as many
as 300,000 Koreans live in Los Angeles
many of them in an area known as
Koreatown some blacks see the Koreans as
a merchant class that takes advantage of
the black community
we are deeply concerned that this
incident may be detrimental to the
positive efforts between the two
communities in order to strengthen our
bond we will actively join with the
african-american community to develop
measures to prevent further tragedy
[Music]
it is now a time for healing it is not a
time for rhetoric which serves no
purpose other than to fuel the fire it's
like throwing gasoline on a fire that's
already burning it is my opinion that
mrs. du is not a danger to the community
and that she is not going to reoffending
law when I see one I know a person who
presents a danger to the community when
I see one when I don't I treat that
person as something other than that
[Music]
there would be all killed with a video
with eyewitnesses and this is what
you'll get
a judge who's probably never been down
here a judge this community a judge
decided that the rice was not valuable
enough your pastor was killed a family
was killed racism is not the Korean
killing her racism is a quite system the
killer we have to show that we are
resilient to the salvation of our people
to be simply Vista
[Applause]
[Music]
judge Barnard Kamen's caught observers
by surprise when he reversed himself and
announced that he would grant a change
of venue in the trial of the four police
officers charged in connection with the
beating of motorist Rodney King the
change of venue motion is greatly
entwined with whether we can get jurors
and I'm very concerned whether we can
get jurors who are I'm tainted other
high-profile cases such as those of
Charles Manson and Robert Kennedy
Assassins Syria and Sirhan were not
transferred out of Los Angeles despite
high publicity but defense attorneys say
this case is different everyone has
opinion on the guilt or innocence of
these defendants and that's why it will
be very difficult to get a fair trial to
move the trial away from the swarming
controversy in the LA media the venue
was changed to the Simi Valley a mostly
white suburb of Los Angeles where many
police officers live Simi Valley is a
town of 100,000 people just 35 miles
north of Los Angeles Simi Valley
residents are 88% white just one and a
half percent of the people who live here
are black
[Music]
you never know the right thing to wait a
long time finally get it going a good
feeling
[Music]
did you say anything to mr. King yes
what did you say to him
yelled at him to lay down on the ground
get down on the ground a series of those
commands a series yes you repeated it
right and tell the jury what happened
next
hey I continued to hit him and then
knocked him to the ground yell at him to
stay on the ground and he repeated the
motion again getting up again
I was completely in fear for my life
scared to death that if this guy got
back up he was gonna take my gun away
from me or there was gonna be a shooting
and I was doing everything I could to
keep him down on the ground at any time
during this evening did it go through
your mind that this was not a human
being that you were beating no he wasn't
an animal was he no sir just wasn't him
like one he was just acting like one yes
sir was he acting like a gorilla no sir
now this call that involved these
African Americans was it in a jungle
you know what a jungle no was it at the
zoo no were there any gorillas around I
didn't see any I'm thinking that mr.
King has been subjected to an enormous
amount of a pain and he's not it's
almost as if his body is anesthetized to
the pain what were you thinking now I
was thinking that I have exhausted all
of the use of force that I have short of
deadly force at this time I'm thinking
at this time I mean they're gonna have
to use a chokehold or my weapon and why
didn't you want to use a chokehold sir
because in Los Angeles the chokehold is
associated with death of blacks
how do you view looking at this
videotape sir it's violent and it's
brutal was this anything that you
enjoyed no why was it done it's done to
control an aggressive combative suspect
and sometimes police work is brutal it's
the fact of life everyday regular folks
from the public file in to watch the
trial and you can too if you could beat
the rush
actually you have a pretty good chance
and we have 17 seats allocated for the
public however the other seats that we
have reserved if people don't show up
for those seats then we immediately open
them up to the public if you want to
come here though here's the little
advice they should dress appropriately
for court of course nothing that says
anything about the trial itself or any
type of racial slurs on anything that
might be misconstrued by anyone
[Music]
stopping the video at 350 102 have you
seen mr. King swinging anyone you know I
have have you seen him punching anyone
no I have your testimony then at any
point after 3 4220 any baton blow
received by mr. king is unreasonable and
unnecessary yes sir it is
as sergeant could not been there to
control that situation as ugly as it
looks
Rodney King wouldn't have been home now
and maybe sergeant Koon would have had
to go tell some officers family why they
didn't come home you've got this man
down he's not doing anything he's not
trying to escape he's not trying to
resist when you reach that point on that
tape where you say enough is enough
that's when unreasonable force starts
our whole system of justice is based on
the belief that if we get 12 people from
the community to fairly and
dispassionately decide this issue devoid
of prejudice and bias then the truth
will come out justice will be done think
ahead and make a decision now about
which you will be able to say years from
now I was true to my oath I was true to
the law I was true to myself
[Music]
she's a package for the opposite yes sir
defendant
you support those guys you better
believe it why those guys are keeping
yeah yeah they're holding the jungle bag
tiger I'm jungle no sir
I think the defendants are jungle people
okay for you to support those defendants
is another is an indication of your
humanity your immorality you got a
constitutional right of poor judgment
and your exercise right now you have a
constitutional right of just
inconspicuous inhumanities keep your
mouth shut I didn't ask you down I have
a constitutional right to freedom of
speech right now aim it somewhere else
yeah
good morning sergeant
the barbecue is great looks like you're
dressed for it today I got my clothes
can you just tell us what it's like the
last few days for you no not really it's
just down David I have nothing to hide
really finicky need according to me what
do you think of the doughnuts I know
it's the ability doesn't open it yet
excuse me mr. Winn I was waiting right
now
waiting yeah no I mean for the verdict
how do you feel about got to be really
tough
[Music]
so let's go to Brian live now at the
courthouse in Simi Valley
well not everybody is in a state of
nervous state of nervousness just
waiting for this decision to come down
right now there are people outside there
was a beefed up security here for what
we don't know but I'm supposing that
they're prepared for whatever may arise
in the event of a verdict so everyone's
in a state of purpose anticipation 5 4 3
2 1 hello I'm told that we have the
courtroom verdict so we will go live
there now verdicts been reached on all
counts as to all defendants who are
mentioned in those counts and have you
brought with you the verdict forms for
those counts okay would you hand them to
the bailiff place
title of cordon cause we the jury in the
above-entitled action find the defendant
Lawrence M Powell not guilty of the
crime of assault by force likely to
produce great bodily injury and with a
deadly weapon the violation of Penal
Code section two four or five a1 felony
as charged in count one of the Amended
indictment this 29th day of April 1992
signed by the foreman we the jury in the
above-entitled action find the defendant
Timothy E when not guilty of the crime
of assault by force likely to produce
great bodily injury and with a deadly
weapon we the jury in the above-entitled
action find the defendant Theodore J
Pacino not guilty of the crime of
assault by force likely to produce great
bodily injury and with a deadly weapon
we the jury in the above-entitled action
find the defendant Stacy C Koon not
guilty of the crime of assault by force
likely to produce great bodily injury
and with a deadly weapon ladies and
gentlemen of the jury are these our
verdicts so say you won so say you all
[Music]
the jury in the Los Angeles police
brutality trial has just reached its
verdict the four police officers who
were videotaped repeatedly beating an
unarmed man were found not guilty on all
but one count one of the four police
officers seen on video tape
[Applause]
racism didn't enter into the jury's
deliberations none of the jurors block
there were ten whites one Asian and one
Hispanic they this jury told the world
that what we all saw with their own eyes
wasn't a crime today that jury asked us
to accept the senseless and brutal
beating of a helpless man today that
jury said that we should tolerate such
conduct by those who are sworn to
protect and serve my friends I'm here to
tell this jury no no our eyes did not
deceive us we saw what we saw what we
saw was a crime you got another white
jury saying that it's okay for white
cops to beat up black people and that's
racist I'm American style and it's been
that way from the get he's making it bad
for all the good cops if they're gonna
let dirty cops off how's that the guy
who's trying to do his job bill for us
to try to go back to tell black people
in the community that justice is blind
they say you write it is so blind and
they can't see us it is so blind to
whenever something happens to one of us
we get the max if we don't get killed
first and so it is blind in my streets
with a belly full beer
I don't think I have to respond to them
they have to respond to themselves to
make their own decision they have all
the facts in front of them I would hope
and that's what they should base it on
it shouldn't be any sort of an emotional
thing I'm glad that you guys showed this
to the world to let them see how black
people are treated in this country you
know you guys do not respect us we you
feel with sub-creatures if I went a beat
if I went a beat your dog the way they
beat this man I'd be in jail these guys
are going off out to have a dream
emerges from this verdict to the rest of
the country do you think why don't we
say the rest of the world
President Bush stands up to challenge
leaders of nations around the world to
respect human rights and to not engage
in a denial of those rights to citizens
they're in laughing they're gonna point
to this videotape and remember the name
Rodney King in South Central LA get
together get out in the street stop
killing each other and let's deal with
what the real problem is white people
white people you got all the economic
power you sell in the country to the
Japanese we've been here 437 years and
don't get nothing
I've had it sends a bad message it says
it's okay to go ahead and beat somebody
when they're down and kick the crap out
of them if it's not videotaped don't
worry about another brother office it
won't turn you in and if a brother
officer does turn you don't worry
Leggett white jurors or whoever it takes
and will you walk and you're protected
by the system you're backed up by the
system in fact it would happen here what
happen anywhere is disgusting it's a
good time folks if you got a plane
ticket captured it and get the heck out
of Dodge this is gonna be a bad place to
live
[Applause]
racist piece of cheering them on
he's cheering him on man I know cheering
here
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight we must tell our children one
more time stay cool become that for
african-american children and adults
freedom is not yet a reality in the
United States
[Applause]
[Music]
talking about peace every time somebody
talked about peace we get a
[Applause]
[Music]
he's helped get his ass kicked I don't
like bullies
and me now with when roving reporters
here we come
mr. number three man were both destroyed
no oh we got many officers as many
people running
[Music]
[Applause]
the areas
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm a tree what I'm not
over 400 years our people have suffered
not only civil rights but the right to
be a human being don't fall victim to
the division use the s United for all a
cross-section of the community today
because one of our brothers have been
unjustly beat and it has been justified
by a jury that shows us that we can't
get justice in America how long do we
have to see these things
how long before we come together in how
many more Bradley Keene nothing to be
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going live in a second stand by
everybody keep a live picture okay
[Music]
[Applause]
right
yeah we kill it apparently groups of
youths are on the streets of South
Central Los Angeles there are reports
that they are throwing rocks and bottles
[Applause]
let's get the latest on the situation
now and go to a news copter 13 Kim
you're looking at a live picture there's
been a mini riot in this location
Tom's liquor store has been looted at
this point
[Music]
[Applause]
please go ahead okay
now I've been attentive alert for this
area they've set up a command post and
that officers have been ordered to stay
out of this area
[Music]
understand we have a helicopter shot now
this is over the command center that's
at 54th and Van Ness can see certainly
there are the concentration of police
vehicles a fire department had to wear
the head uation at Hardin Army they are
holding back on their refund for the
present time we're not going that area
we're working a number of radio support
news copter 13 what we're doing is we
have people aboard that are relaying
information to the police helicopters
and the emergency operations center of
the city we're also showing a live
picture that they're seeing they know
what's going on down here
[Music]
they're jacking every
that comes to a stop here at this
intersection rocks and bottles being
thrown at another car they're now
pulling the door off the
they're checking the driver and beating
the driver
was enter this area that's his only
crime
hit the siren uh my god
all these are absolutely brutal attack
pictures
gives up now he's closer toward he's
still bleeding all over they try to get
back into his truck
getting back into his truck I hope he
has enough power to
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
we're gonna go in deeper and show you
this thing what's going on let's go this
way
[Music]
at least over here very angry people
they're doing signs and have taken over
Los Angeles Street and again the
situation's very volatile people they
involving the office are slowing things
[Music]
Ron is this an organized demonstration
or I think he'll I think it started a
pleasure organized demonstration and and
then it grew and grew and now now it has
been for the past hour or so pretty much
a standoff here
[Applause]
[Music]
where you're looking and one of the
partner centers large stations one of
the guard stations they have taken it
over they are breaking the windows
trying to seal off the street the group
basically just marching right down the
middle of the street
it is a multiracial crowd it is not
enough predominantly any color there's a
fellow who's lighting the freezer he not
yes going along block to block
nobody stopping I mean one tree after
another these bearded palms with the
dead frogs hanging down great fuel for
an arsonist
[Music]
[Applause]
I talked with some of the officers a
little while ago things they really
don't know what to do right now our TV
cameras all over I don't think anybody
really knows what to do and how to get
this under control
[Applause]
before still working Civic Center right
turn 1.2 stephanie is that you you want
to change that to house widespread is
the violence because it'll be hard to
talk about okay well at this evening we
understand that there are about 20 fires
burning mostly in South Central Los
Angeles this is a predominantly black
area of the city this is a super
swapmeet location someone actually a
group of over 100 people went into this
location and looted it and every time
they go in and loot after they are done
looting they set fire to the structure
[Music]
what you need the videotape we don't
think I everyone in so take yourself
for the first time tonight from Daryl
gates who is holding a news conference
let's go to in-laws it's again I think
most of its concentrated in
south-central Los Angeles area
but problem is you find many locations
where there are no officers and that
needs to be corrected and we're trying
to do that a strictly game
this reported structure fire for life or
[Applause]
[Music]
they're dispatching LAPD units along
with all fire trucks that respond to
major emergency blazes for protection
but with respect to trying to get LAPD
serviced or anything else folks you're
on your own down there
[Music]
there are fires burning there are people
being beaten there is looting that is a
dangerous night city of Los Angeles
[Music]
I'm advised that there is someone from
the Secretary of State's office on the
way over to accept this proclamation of
a state emergence of a state of
emergency for a Los Angeles City in Los
Angeles County this is in response to
requests by Mara Bradley as a result of
the discussions that we have had there
will be as many as 750 California
Highway patrolmen additionally we have
made available some 2,000 National
Guardsmen they are on standby prepared
to move transport has been arranged and
it is our purpose here at the state
government level to restore law and
order and to minimize the danger to the
residents of the area this is a matter
that needs to be settled in the courts
and not in the streets thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
White House officials are scrambling at
this very moment to produce a statement
from President Bush nobody expected that
verdict the way it came down there's
nothing really that the White House can
do about that verdict but it does
present a huge political problem many
civil rights leaders thought that
President Bush has been weak on civil
rights civil rights promises must be
straight about this we have no access to
the White House we had one meeting since
I have been in Congress what the
President did was Performa it was
courtesy but there is no relationship
administration officials say that the
Justice Department had in fact launched
a civil rights investigation into the
Rodney King beating but once state
charges were brought they sort of put
that on hold now it's unclear at this
moment exactly where that investigation
stands faith they would almost seem at
this point Jimmy they'd have to pick it
up again you cannot ignore that all of
this is coming in a presidential
election year you know that I don't
think he's done enough that I think we
have had too much division and too
little harmony I think there's been too
little effort to bring people together
across racial lines this is a human
problem people in this country don't
trust each other and don't trust the
system and the political system is too
often divided people by race and that is
the urgent task for America today our
diversity will either be our undoing our
the source of our greatest strength I am
angry and I have a right to that anger
and the people out there have a right to
that anger we don't want anybody killed
none of us believe in violence but
there's some angry people in America and
young black males in my district are
feeling at this moment if they could not
get a conviction with the Rodney King
video available to the jurors that there
can be no justice in America
[Applause]
[Music]
1:02 3kj l-82 here in los angeles and
we're discussing all the violence in the
aftermath and the directions to go as
far as they say an incident here vent
your anger your frustration your your
hard feelings not out on the streets not
breaking windows not looting not writing
but you know I guess if some people say
just punch on me punch on the radio
station talk to us over the lines let's
go back to the phone lines let's see how
you feel this morning because this is
not the way for us to vent our
frustration this is what they expect us
to do I've been lifting the kjh on my
life only have three words for what's
happening and those are the same three
words that was uttered during the 1965
riot and you're going to say those bad
words have burden baby burn yeah thank
you Robert this is your aunt's store
guess that was a liquor store here this
was a 99-cent store and she has another
store on Crenshaw and that one is dog
it's terrible absolutely terrible
what can you say they said it all
yesterday
and this is out come up
this is not sort of a passive am upon
some they go in them as a radio Korea
yet pure use to go his Madonna AG dijo
que probably be Kubek Kashyap am new
Tsunade Onan even donate saw hanging
drapes a gap a junction gotta go
although Haneda Ebanks don't shake on
Hanna can get their application in the
APA acapella like you go I don't think
any other people any other ways any
other colors just does it happened it
happened that's it
you're gonna believe again we're gonna
good attached to me you are keep our
presentation continues and I say we
believe here and we even live here
and
the city is still officially under a
state of emergency the City Council is
going to meet discuss how to proceed
from here the purpose of this meeting is
to discuss the necessary action ability
of the state of emergency in the city of
Los Angeles declared by the mayor on
April 29th
okay mr. Holden mr. president members
I'm sure you've heard from each of my
colleagues before I arrived and
certainly you've seen them on TV
asking for calm and regretting the
tragedy that took place last night and
continuing in our city the question is
how do we stop it if we have a pretty
good idea that's likely to occur and it
will unless we have a presence but you
got to start deploying right now I tell
you
handwriting's on the wall
I can't really tell because we're on the
radio and I can barely see the
television are people still looting at
this time yes they are
I seen him when I was coming into work
they still going into stores and they
still taking things going if I decide
man thank you
while the looting seems to continue
unabated the mood at least seems to be
very calm today we can right through
that it says factory direct sale this is
the biggest sale they've probably ever
seen it's like people are alluding
anything they can get their hands on
here's a guy with a plant even coming
right out the front window and taking
off I've been taking pictures at all
this is exciting
it's wrong but it's exciting but you
know something here where are the police
where are all the police if chief gates
said would being ready for this chief
gates yes just to emphasize our
deployment will increase substantially
and we hope that that will satisfy the
need now now there are some place now
everyone's running here they are the
police are coming for that they must be
two or three
coming out of that store right now I
don't know how many people fit in that
store but they're all running out
because there's the police finally
moving in the police can arrest this
many people they just go running with
their merchandise and the police really
aren't running after they can't run
after we just don't have enough people
are doing so as we chase them away they
come right back it's my judgment that
the overwhelming majority of those who
are engaged in that unlawful activity
now are not the law-abiding citizens of
this community but those who are taking
advantage of an opportunity what are you
doing are you embarrassed you know this
is illegal why did you do this I don't
know
come into
where are the National Guard troops that
have been promised why do we not see
them though why hasn't the National
Guard been called out that's a mystery
too and we have had reports that several
hundred are in the area and we expect to
see and hear from them soon I understand
the idea that they could make things
worse but then you could say that about
the police - I mean how much worse
doesn't need to get
[Music]
[Applause]
you know Breanna singing an anime on one
you joining our Andromeda
[Music]
[Laughter]
we have a fire that's broken out in
Koreatown across Western Avenue have
there been any kind of disturbances in
Koreatown I think this is the first
we've heard about this kind of activity
yes that's right Pat this is just
interrupted I don't see any official
firefighters in attendance are there any
in the area no no firefighters here good
tune bedico boot a cool person was in an
ecological Trimboli now Roger go we
needed ABS at regression winter please
woman car that can find out there
we are open the union token Indians have
crumbled or homina homina Gujarat serve
the kitchen from Halloween Johannine for
dinner and they've taken the law into
their own hands position themselves on
the roof they are also armed with clubs
the Aryans here have prepared to protect
themselves against anything that may
come their way the police didn't come
here
we need addition of God in here we have
no police support whatsoever people are
driving by shooting at us and we have to
do something about it always dressed for
war games that's right and it's
certainly not a game to those people
that are on the roof and are carrying
rifles and lots of boxes of ammunition
that's like
they're shooting at us so far we'll be
shooting up but when it comes to worse
we're not gonna see the rioting up side
we're gonna shoot at them Eli this is
Linda more live some of the Korean shop
owners here pulled out of their stores
and they start pulling out weapons
there's some cars that have some
I think we should
I don't know if you've got a slide you
don't have a slide but you can see our
three fires and
that fire was one of three fires that
had recently broken out the Hollywood
area the other was just east of that and
frankly up in the air here we can see
fires easily beyond the Watson Compton
area clearly the buyers are spreading
flames but there
we are getting reports of looting from
all over Los Angeles and also
surrounding areas is not confined to
south-central not confined to the city
of Los Angeles it's all over
Vernon convalescent hospital a fire over
there somebody set a fire in the
convalescent house the fire department
the police department and everybody else
is trying to help scattered all over the
city so the fires are burning out of
control
[Music]
[Applause]
twenty-one confirmed dead at this time
at least 572 injured including two
firefighters this number is staggering I
don't know exactly how to tell you this
but 916 structure fires are burning in
the Los Angeles area 916
[Music]
what a mess
there's people down there with
automatically attack Wilshire
Neela's Culver City on the right it's
like they're feeling so pressed
[Music]
well this going on with people
other than you know a black thing you
know what I mean I mean he got some
people that worked 60 to 80 hours a week
and still have bill collectors calling
did they see their bosses fill out these
mercs and these roasts every day and
struck them on the back and told it's
gonna be alright
you know how long can it last
that's not right
that right what y'all do
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
the California Army National Guard has
been deployed to assist the Sheriff's
Department and Los Angeles Police
Department in a mutual aid operation to
restore law and order and to protect
life and property in the Los Angeles
County
[Music]
frustrated today by the parents of
muffins of the LA officials to use the
guard on the street dan I don't think
there was reluctance I think that there
was some delay for logistical reasons
reasons that have to do with equipping
the guard the chief problem has been
with respect to ammunition the troops
came but the ammunition didn't they came
with some ammunition not the full
complement that they should have the
problem was that it was slow in coming
from Camp Roberts
you start out where we are right now
we're gonna head to eighty ones position
at a kilos position and weapons comfy
position we're going to come over like
that
I didn't expect to be on US soil doing
this job ever ever tough woman done
they're getting the corn or something we
liking load like a little round the
chamber never thought it would be done
not in our own country it's amazing
you've got to know
who you're looking at and who you're
thinking about whereas in the Gulf it
was a lot easier you know
hey take a corner stay down you see it
if you take mounds
take it up go home get back off go get
off the streets leave the area these are
the police LAPD going up and down Pico
telling resident the curfew is in effect
now get off the streets
[Music]
Ram three gram Watteau Ram three this is
RAM one over
round three up yeah
they're gonna turn on the sprinklers out
here so to keep it wet down there be
careful you don't get up all right
the water pressure if they need it over
here on these houses turn it off I don't
think it's gonna make that big a
difference what I'm trying to do is
avoid the sparks
[Music]
be doing
[Applause]
I know people got injured because of
polluting and there were police across
the street watching it there's nothing
they could do it was already there were
too many people just going crazy
stepping all over each other
racism in the United States of America
is as American as Los Angeles Mayor Tom
Bradley and police officials said today
that they're regaining control over the
city police chief Daryl gates admitted
that the police force got a slow start
Wednesday afternoon when the violence
began and gates and fire chief Donald
Manning conceded that the city's forces
were overwhelmed fire fighters Don
bulletproof vest says they fought the
scores of new fires that were set last
night there was still about 40 fires
burning early this morning
[Music]
at least 35 people are now said to have
lost their lives more than 1300 people
have been injured and 3,000 arrested the
city remains under a dusk-to-dawn curfew
with many stores and malls closed
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone I'm Ross Becker
here in the channel 13 newsroom we are
interrupting programming this afternoon
momentarily we expect to hear a
statement from someone whose name will
be indelibly connected to all of the
violence we have seen over the last
couple of days in Los Angeles and that
is Rodney King and we're standing by
it's been great anticipation certainly
mr. King has not made public statements
he has been really the the Invisible Man
and all this and I detect some movement
through the crowd yep I see here he
comes
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen I want to thank you
all for coming
Rodney King has this to say to all the
people of Los Angeles and all the people
of the cities of the United States so
caught up in there's horror and hate the
killing the burning the looting the
chaos must stop now the time for healing
is upon us Rodney King has prepared a
very brief statement
people um I just want to say you know
can we can we all get along can we can
we get along
can we stop making it making our before
but uh for the older people in and the
and the kids and I mean we've got enough
smoke here in Los Angeles
[Music]
let alone to deal with the setting these
fires and and thing is just not right
it's not right and it's not it's not
gonna it's not gonna change anything
we've got it we've got to quit we've got
to quit you know after all I mean I can
understand the first upset for the first
two hours after the verdict but to go on
to keep going on like like this and to
see the security guard shot on on the
ground it uh it's it's just not right
it's just not right because those people
will never go home to to their families
again and I mean please we can we can
get along here we we all can get along
we just got it together you know I mean
we're all stuck here for a while this
you know let's
let's try to work it out let's try to
beat it you know let's try and work it
out thank you very much
Steven Steve and I will be available if
you have any question
[Music]
night tonight
to
[Music]
tonight I want to talk to you about
violence in our cities and justice for
our citizens what we saw last night in
the night before in Los Angeles is not
about civil rights it's not a message of
protest it's been the brutality of a mob
pure and simple and let me assure you I
will use whatever force is necessary to
restore order within one hour of the
verdict I directed the Justice
Department to move into high gear on its
own independent criminal investigation
into the case you must understand that
our system of justice provides for the
peaceful orderly means of addressing
this frustration we must respect the
process of law whether or not we agree
with the outcome in a civilized society
there can be no excuse no excuse for the
murder arson theft and vandalism that
have terrorized the law-abiding citizens
of Los Angeles none of this is what we
wish to think of as American it's as if
we were looking in a mirror that
distorted our better selves and turned
us ugly we cannot let that happen we
cannot do that to ourselves if we are to
remain the most vibrant and hopeful
nation on earth we must allow our
diversity to bring us together not drive
us apart the violence will end justice
will be served
hope will return thank you and may God
bless the United States of America
President George Bush and his address to
the nation from The Oval Office
time for your reactions once again from
around the country for Washington
Maryland here on the air first of all
mr. Bush spoke at the last 48 hours is
this the first time he's noticed that
America has a problem it's always had a
problem from its inception from 1776
when they said all men were created
equal and we had slavery it was striking
to me that there was no direct statement
to the African American population and
there was completely missing any sense
of a reality about how a national leader
might move people towards reconciliation
people have to see that they're gonna
have to make their voices heard if they
allow when they hear a politician to try
to explain this away as being thugs and
murderers things will not change this is
going to be a people movement people can
move politicians the community leads
they don't follow politicians follow
they don't lead and that's what we have
to remember
[Music]
vamos a tener que aquí de latino de
Vere's quiere employer esta ciudad de
fátima kate reaganomics KOA which was
granted it woke me no return of
immediate medical attention and interest
oh Allah bless you that yeah it's
important to see the full scope the
burning the looting and the cleaning up
a personal opinion is just that you know
everybody need to work together and if
this could just continue it would be
wonderful but you know I don't think it
will I think you know a few people say
okay put in my time I help clean and
then I couldn't do anything
[Music]
justice in the king is we miss abuse
[Applause]
what
throughout history the only power I
believe that power poor people have in
powerless people have in this country
comes from our unruly behavior
resistance to an order that would place
us at the bottom of the totem
[Applause]
[Music]
this is where it began this is where the
fuse was lighted it began with the
arrests by white officers of the
California Highway Patrol of two young
Negroes one on a charge of drunk driving
there was an argument there was a
scuffle history of police brutality
quickly spread through the community up
the street a block or so in that
direction a church where a Negro leaders
pleaded for peace and were rejected
found that way the busy intersection
where cars were overturned and burned
where other cars were stoned where a
television technician was pulled from
his wagon and almost beaten to death
what has changed the only thing that was
done was that massive forces were
brought in to suppress the actual overt
action the incident is not an isolated
incident
the difference this time is that we have
the proof
[Music]
we get a foot
[Applause]
in civilized society there can be no
excuse for the murder pillage looting
and arson have nothing to do with civil
rights
[Music]
[Applause]
I was thinking to ever stop really that
mean that may not be like this but they
never stopped
[Applause]
[Music]
a crisis in our country says the McKown
Commission so serious and explosive is
the situation that unless it is checked
the August riots may be only a curtain
raiser - what could blow up one day in
the future what shall it avail our
nation if we can place a man on the moon
but cannot cure the sickness in our
cities this is bill stout for CBS
reports in Los Angeles good night
you
[Music]